what's going on guys this is Rob and I
wanted to talk about what with I guess
with actually comics number 1000 coming
out I want to talk about why BC decided
to kill Superman and you know I don't
really expect this to be like a huge
usually popular video not at all I mean
honestly the death of Superman it's kind
of an beat to death but it is one of my
favorite topics to discuss which we've
talked about this before to a degree not
in this capacity not it's like a
complete thing but of course that's your
man happened in 1992 and and it was it
was interesting when it took place um
that was just before I started reading
Marvel Comics and so even then like even
when I started reading I said wasn't
really into DC so but I knew about it I
mean I knew about Superman dying and I
knew that it was a big to-do who was a
pretty huge thing I mean it made it made
like national news when DC killed
Superman which is exactly what they were
shooting for they were shooting for the
idea that they would receive national
attention that that all eyes would be
drawn to the Man of Steel um a lot of
people sort of look at the death of
Superman and they look at Batman
nightfall it's kind of like the death
knell of the comic book industry
basically saying like you know there
were so many varying covers were
released and like kind of stuff that
that's what led to the near collapse the
big comic busts of the 1990s but one of
the things that kind of gets thrown out
there when people talk about the day the
Superman died or the you know the
decision to kill him they say well it
all really just came down to the fact
that you know Wonder Brothers had
Superman the adventures of Lois and
Clark and then you know Jerry what do I
said well let's just kill Superman and
then that's that and then the rest is
history
a to a degree it's a little more
complicated than that I mean to a degree
that's true but it is a little more
complicated the death of Superman I
would say was probably about 20 years in
the making I mean it was it was it was
it had been coming for a long time so
Jimmy back to like 1971 Mort Weisinger
had retired and and the retirement of
Mort Weisinger was well it was it was
almost like the nail in the coffin for
for Superman's comics because Mort
Weisinger had the most significant hand
in the development of Superman outside
of Curt Swan who drew him for 30 years
more white singers involvement in the
Superman landscape was was it was it was
immense he took over in like the mid
1950s the late 1950s somewhere between
1956 and 1959 I think it was that was
all done by Julius Schwartz who
basically introduced Barry Allen and
then orchestrated the blending of
science fiction with superhero stories
and then what you had was you had
Weisinger who said well in order for in
order to make Superman succeed in order
to make him into something greater than
just a come of a character we have to
make him like a household name I mean he
was to a degree by then I mean he was
really really popular just among readers
among the readership man you know and
even just with like the general public
but just because a superhero is really
really popular in comics and kind of you
know goes into pop culture doesn't mean
they're gonna stay that way forever and
that was the goal was to turn Superman
into like this massive larger-than-life
concept and so more twice Turner's idea
was adds something new every six months
every six months I don't care what it is
introduce something new and so you know
you had guys like like you know Otto
bender who gave us like Supergirl you
know they had all these crazy things
that were thrown in but it worked it
worked by a huge margin every six months
fans had something new and so because of
that a lot of the DC comics at the time
that were coming out the flash comics
the Green Lantern comic different things
like that they weren't as successful as
they could be because Superman was
literally often space doing things and
if he were reading stories about
Superman being in space why would you
read stories about Green Lantern and
Superman was incredibly fast and he was
racing the flash and him and things like
that and Superman was so fast that he
could basically reach everybody just in
the nick of time
then what reason did you have to read
the flash it was different things like
that you know he was a fighter he was he
always you know fought against the bad
guys so there was really no need to read
Wonder Woman of course those different
comics did have their fan bases and of
course they were getting readership
hence the reason they weren't cancelled
but the fact remains here that when it
came to him as a character Mort
Weisinger just blew up the Superman
mythos and so in 1970 1997 1971 when he
retired the the question that everybody
had was more than what comes next who
can possibly follow this whole thing of
a Mort Weisinger who can keep this this
ship sailing and so Julius Schwartz had
stepped in and again Julius Schwartz was
the person that had kind of orchestrated
the Silver Age of comics and so it made
sense that he would be the one to step
in for those guys who weren't are
familiar with Julius Schwartz he is like
the 1950s equivalent of Jeff Jones in
the modern day and terms of personality
I don't really know I don't know much
about Julius Schwartz outside from the
different stories that like Neal Adams
would tell me whenever I would go to
cons but aside from that like Mike he
was a guy that orchestrated this huge
paradigm shift to MDC and so when when
when Morris won
I can retire Julius Schwartz stepped in
and said well then I'll take care of
Superman
the problem with Mort Weisinger x' idea
of Superman is that he believed he'd
become too powerful and in all honesty
that's what fans liked about Superman
he was basically indestructible and that
was really the challenge that's what
made the story so good by Mort Weisinger
and the various writers who were working
for him was that with Superman stories
pushing him further and further beyond
into the realm of just you know lunacy
for the most part because there were
things like super glasses and because he
could fly you know fly backwards in time
and because you know he could he was
able to outrace infinity take that for
what it's worth because he was able to
do all these crazy things the the
concept became well now now it has to be
bigger this time now it has to be bigger
this time it got bigger and bigger and
larger and larger and it got to the
point where the stories were so crazy
and fantastic but Silver Age Superman is
sort of this embodiment of like how zany
comics were back then pulling a chain of
plan instead of a dying galaxy different
things like that and so because of that
Mort Weisinger said well if we're gonna
make Superman interesting we have to
make him relatable he did the exact
opposite of what Mort Weisinger had done
he basically had had Dennis O'Neil go
through and like I think it was with
with Superman issue number 233 I'm
pretty sure station number 233 they
started a story that ran for like three
parts then it was basically Superman
fighting a version of himself that was
made of Sam and so what this did is it
ended with the story but basically super
with this sand version of Superman
defeated his powers were cut in half he
was half as strong as he was before
Kryptonite was totally rendered inert so
he basically had Superman who was half
as strong as you was before with no real
weaknesses outside of magic and fans
hated him oh they despised it and they
despised us so much four years later DC
set it all back they said okay but
that's the nature of comics right the
nature of comics is you don't know what
works until you change what works that's
the only way to really know the only way
to really know that more Weisinger his
his style of you know editorial control
and his style of having different people
write different ways no one could really
know that worked until you changed that
because it was Superman you know while
he did increase poppy and did increase
the popularity under Mort Weisinger you
didn't know if it was just the natural
progression of Superman because of
exposure because comics were regaining
popularity as a result of them being
blended with science fiction because he
was the first superhero he's the one
that set the whole
superhero genre in motion or if it was
because of what more Weisinger did and
that's what we learned
why singer was the one who had basically
made Superman popular throughout the
1950s in the 1960s by just telling these
crazy stories or at least making him
more popular than he was and so with
Julius Schwartz basically going through
it say okay fine we'll set things back
to the way they were before the damage
had been done there was really no way to
come back from that and the reason for
that was because of Gerry Conway so
Gerry Conway wrote a story in 1971
called the night when Stacey died and
this story changed the it really like
shifted comics in a new direction
because never before never before had
there ever been an instance one of what
a Maine superhero had failed so
disastrously that their love interest on
that didn't happen that never happened
their friends might die a sidekick might
die even another superhero might die but
like the love interest that never
happened that that never took place and
it was mind-blowing when that happened
not only that the potential existed
within the confines of the story then
not only did when Stacey died but it was
possibly spider-man who actually killed
her and so it was it was it was nuts
when that story came out and people were
just like wow I mean in in truth like
that kind of a community was ready for a
new direction
you know the stories have been veiny and
fantastic and science fictiony and
different things like that that was cool
but it had been that way for about a
decade and a half people were ready for
something else they were ready for like
a new direction of comic books and Gerry
Conway gave them that with the story of
the night when Stacey died the funny
thing about this though was that at the
same time Gwen Stacy died
Batman was struggling for the most part
and that's really what this these three
comes these three things this thing
comes down to is Batman basically
regaining popularity gwen stacy dying
and the Julius Schwartz decision on
Superman Batman was kind of an
afterthought I mean in this three
there's three part discussion that we're
talking about we can really view that
now Batman it's kind of like a
background character he was just there
you know he's just a person who was
there and there were stories about him
but he wasn't very popular at all he had
a little bit of popularity in the 1960s
because of the Adam West show which
helped to kind of like drive new
readership to the Batman comics but once
the show went off the air like the sales
of the comics tanked again because
nobody had a reason to buy him and so
with that that whole thing you know
reaching its its fruition in 1985 what
this meant was that Superman was
continually going down in popularity and
then Batman was stagnant he was just
kind of sitting
he was going down a little bit but not
nearly as bad as Superman and so what
happened is the 1985 DC grabbed a
freight miller and they brought him over
from from daredevil and they said you
know basically give us a new story of
Batman and Frank Miller wrote The Dark
Knight Returns where Batman was older
and he was grizzled he was far more
cynical he'd retired the Joker returned
Gotham was overridden by mobs or by you
know different different you know
criminal groups and things like that it
was like the worst case scenario for
what would happen if that man just quit
one day and so what ended up happening
is in the Dark Knight Returns that story
had all these incredibly and amazing
themes that helped to kind of revitalize
interest in the character of Bruce Wayne
and the role the Batman played but what
really popped it all off and we're
really set it all off was Batman beating
Superman that never happened they were
always friends they always teamed up
they always had adventures together that
was the nature of their characters
Batman defeating Superman was massive
when it happened because it was believed
to be something that Batman just wasn't
able to do it wasn't a part of his
wheelhouse no way he would have been
able to pull that off and so from there
it was just a matter of watching
Batman's popularity just just begin just
skyrocket I mean was almost just like it
just took off
you know the Dark Knight Returns was
followed by Batman year one and with
that like Batman overtook Superman
because now what you had is you had a
guy that people could look to and say
well he's not just a crazy guy dressed
as a bat he's a crazy guy dressed as a
bat who beats Superman and so people
were just like damn so now they had like
a huge interest in Batman where they
didn't really have it before and once
new people started getting and what's
new readership started flowing in to the
Batman comics then people began to
realize he's a lot more relatable than
Superman I mean sure the only thing that
really separates Batman from them is
like his extreme wealth and his extreme
intelligence with enough time anybody
could physically become as capable as
Batman is with enough time they could
learn the martial arts of Batman does
that's how the the viewership looked at
him didn't have the money or the
resources he had but they certainly had
like the same physical body with the
same physical limitations now that
wasn't superhuman he had to eat he had
to sleep he had a drink you know drink
water he had all the same limitations
they didn't so they could see themselves
becoming Batman and so in that moment
what it did is it kind of threw through
Superman into the background Superman
just kind of kind of became a character
who was there and had stories but DC's
the perspective their viewpoint at the
time where that Superman has to be
number one he's Superman
he's the
for a superhero if he's the first
superhero he's been everything to
everybody all these years then there's
no reason why Superman shouldn't be the
highest-selling publication and so at
that time because of the fact that that
Warner Brothers had commissioned for the
release of Superman the adventures of
Lois and Clark that story was hugely
popular you know because it combined you
know drama and intrigue and you know
whodunit mystery and then all those
different things you know along with
Dean Cain just looking actually pretty
cool as Superman and so what DC wanted
to do their whole philosophy was okay
since like 1938 Superman and Lois Lane
have been beating around the bush we
know they're gonna get together but they
just kind of been doing the dance and
you know and so on so forth so so let's
just do that like let's just have them
get married like let's just have
Superman and Lois Lane get married
that'll be the big thing that'll draw
interest back into the Superman comics
because finally is that it's the wedding
of a lifetime Superman and Lois Lane get
married the issue with this was that the
the Superman Lois and Clark show was
already gonna do that it was already
scripted it was already planned all that
work had already been put in and it
wouldn't make any sense to go through
and change all those wheels to stop all
those wheels from moving when it was a
lot easier to stop the wheels from
moving in comics and so the decision was
made do not have Superman and Lois Lane
get married in DC Comics do something
else and that's when the story comes in
of Jerry Ordway saying well then let's
just kill him and so DC said okay fine
let's kill Superman
and so they ended up killing off the Man
of Steel the downside of this and in
fact max max landis had a really really
cool video about this that I think is
the death and return of Superman is what
it's called and he's 100% right when he
says that what happened was that after
the death of Superman
the sales have actually comics tanked to
the sales of Superman's comics taint and
never came back they never quite
recovered to where they were before he
died in 1992 and the reason why was
because people thought they were part of
something momentous they thought they
were part of something huge the death of
Superman like my god the death of the
first superhero kneel when a superhero
died in comic books they stay dead they
never came back they always they stay
dead forever that's the way it was you
know Bucky Barnes died and or at least
was believed to have died at the end of
the original Captain America comics at
the known and was the 1940s or 50s or
something on those lines you know and
and that was the end of that Bucky
Barnes was never gonna be seen or heard
from again Uncle Ben died in you know it
was a spy my number one
think it was Rigby amazing fantasy
number 15 whichever one it was Uncle Ben
died and he was never gonna come back he
was gonna be gone forever when
superheroes died they said you know and
when important characters I should say
in comic books died they stayed dead and
so to everybody who looked everybody who
went out and bought Action Comics you
know actually how much number 75 I think
it was everybody who went out and or
maybe was Superman 75 whichever one it
was everybody who went out and bought
the death of Superman the comic where he
died did not believe he was ever gonna
make his return and then he did and then
he showed back up six months to a year
later someone was lines and fans felt
betrayed they felt cheated
they felt like they'd like the rugged
been pulled out from under them you know
like it was a bait and switch and and
that put people in a pretty sour tone a
lot of people felt duped and tricked you
know it led to the collapse of the kind
of book industry but I don't know I mean
it is kind of interesting like when you
get into the meat and potatoes of why BC
killed Superman it's a lot more complex
than the idea of well you know Jerry
Ordway suggested it so they did it you
know it wasn't like I mean at the end of
the day it was a napkin idea you know
but the fact remains it had been
building up to that point it was
something that had been you know was a
DC intended or not it was something that
had been progressing in that direction
for a long long time but anyway I just
want to go and throw that out there
figured you guys might enjoy this
thought I might be kind of a cool video
to celebrate actually college number
1000 coming out here in the next couple
days if you guys are new here to
commerce explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]